the struggle to save lives is now tied
up with the struggle to find oxygen
and every person in this hospital is
part of that fight
across the indian capital it's almost an
hourly battle
emotionally we are drained we have not
seen so many mortalities
in our icu as well as in our near and
dear ones
i get maybe uh around 50 calls every day
somebody's asking for beds somebody's
asking for cylinder somebody asking for
drugs
we don't have anything available
and patients are dying
india's reported a record number of
coronavirus cases for the fifth day
running
and they're struggling now
is requiring at least 15 liters a minute
that means
at this rate every three hours is a
struggle for us to arrange for the neo
auxin cylinder
they've got nearly double the number of
patients in this hospital
and they're expecting worse to come the
situation is critical right now
this pandemic is the worst we have ever
seen till now
and these two weeks are going to be a
hell for us
i want you to have a look at this
because it's hard to illustrate
the scale of a problem with a country
the size of india
and with the population of india but
this is just what
one hospital has done to cope with a
rising number of
coronavirus patients and it keeps on
rising they've had to build tents
in the car park to cope with the
overspill all these people
are suffering from coronavirus all of
them
need oxygen they can't take in any more
and these are the lucky ones who managed
to get help
international help including from
britain is on its way but it can't come
soon enough with patients struggling for
breath and worrying if their lifelines
will run out
sometimes this is working sometimes
this other cylinder is finishing
so they are
nearing the oxygen level
though it is immediate like
india's calamity is the rest of the
world too
with a new more virulent variant called
a double mutation
and doctors saying they're seeing
alarming resistance to medicines and
vaccines
the double mutant it bypasses everything
even the medicines are not very
effective on that
so the medicines which were very helpful
in the earlier
last week last week which we used to
give in the mild cases it doesn't seem
to work now
there are many more people needing much
more oxygen
and they're having to beg barter and buy
from wherever
i'm buying oxygen at the rate of gold
you know it has the situation come to
that level it was like 20
22 rupees per kg oxygen and today i
sanctioned for 50 rupees
per kg and the black marketing is
happening
render severe injection which is like
4000 rupees or 2000 also
people are buying at 40 000 rupees
the government is urging its citizens
not to panic and not to hoard but the
oxygen demand has risen around 20
nationally with some hospitals coming
within minutes of running out of
supplies
so they're not prepared to listen right
now alex corford
sky news in new delhi